my instinct is to say it's rubbish you
know but it's not I mean certainly dis
government were first to go and still
lead the world in terms of their
commitment pro-rata to the economy the
Americans obviously put more money in
Obama's asked for six billion more I
think you get it but let's look at the
other suppose at big powers let's look
at Germany their number eight in the
queue why they're the economic parallels
of Europe Canada is just slightly below
their commitment in fact the Germans
spent more on one football stadium for
their World Cup than their spending on
people dying of Ebola and as I point out
in Germany three days ago it's a plane
ride from Berlin or Frankfurt or Hamburg
it's one plane right this thing you know
so they have pretensions to global
leadership then lead Russia you've got
it you've got a political gangster you
know beating up a smaller country you
know get with the program help others
were helpless it's an extremely rich
country China has workers down there
very slow getting off the ground are now
committing some of their troops there
specially trained troops to deal with
these emergency situations the Emirates
you know where are they you know they
lecture everyone about this that and the
other you know they are enjoying there's
good Muslims to live a life of charity
where is it a million dollars from these
massively rich oil countries no it's not
good enough you know and I don't want to
hear nonsense from them unless they
accept their global responsibility